[Music]
funny oh you are as you say you're a
you're a cute fun guy but you've played
lots of thugs drug dealers do you when
you do fans when they see you on the
street do they reference that part of
your work all the time yeah yeah I just
flew I was in Israel and I just flew
back this morning and one of the flight
attendants was a fan of weeds and he
came over with a piece of paper and he
was like can you give me an autograph
and he wrote something down for me to
write and he wanted me to write good
luck with your grow room and so so I
wrote it I guess he wanted me to bless
his grow room and in Israel and he's
from from Israel's so I wrote it because
sometimes people will tell me exactly
what they want them to write and you
think I don't this to get me in trouble
it's one thing to sell nice no you Conan
was doing right this right here told you
and I had sex Conan I was nervous I was
like it I would kept looking at him am i
writing the right thing yeah now you're
probably one of your earliest roles was
in the cult hit Dave Chappelle movie
half-baked
and you talk about you know pots big
cult pop movie was that a fun movie to
work on because it's become such a
notorious film yeah I was it was a blast
to work on we shot it all in Toronto so
we were all staying in hotel rooms yeah
and so we after after we would wrap the
day we would all go to Dave's room and
smoke and smoke smoke weed and um and
I'm Esther Road the mom from good times
we play Florida yeah I'm yes she started
we found out that she was complaining
that she was getting these WAAFs of
marijuana smoke going into her room and
we were like yeah we was kind of psyched
that you know Estero was complaining
about his smoking pot next era but I'm
we you know yeah it was the most fun
I've ever had in making a movie we've
had the times over the years you'll
attested to Sandy over the years when
we've been doing the show and Snoop Dogg
is on the show he shows up with his
posse it is absolutely and it's about
through the air-conditioning vents
yes snoopers I was in half baked and he
you know we were smoking fake pot in the
movie and he was the only one who was
like I'm not smoking fake stuff so in
the movie when he smells an actor I have
he was very cold stuff yeah so his when
he's smoking in the movie it's it's real
what we oh now he's in a lot of trouble
I'd like to see that the receipt that
props submitted for that yeah it was for
snow yeah
what did you do early on when you're
struggling in the business what did you
do to support yourself like before you
had kind of started getting regular
roles yeah one of my jobs I used to work
at a photo stock agency as a file I used
to file pictures of celebrities and and
I've reminded pictures like like like
paparazzi yeah so I worked for an agency
that represented paparazzi and and one
of I'm a huge Madonna fan and one of the
photographer's was going to shoot the
girlie show one of Madonna's shows and
he was he came up to me one day he was
like Guillermo you're gonna be my
assistant we're gonna go to the girl
who's showing I'm gonna give you a
camera and you're gonna come with me and
you we and the photographers get to go
in the pit so you're literally right in
front of the stage you know and they get
to go in there for like three songs so
you know I dream come true yeah yeah I
had the camera around my neck and I was
nervous and I remember
Madonna's publicist came into a room and
she looked at all of us and gave us all
bracelets and and you know cut to us
there in the pit and Madonna comes out
and the photographers started taking
pictures and I'm the only one who's
standing there going screaming and then
I would remember that I had to take
pictures
I'm guessing you're not good pictures
and the pictures came out they you know
I saw the pictures afterwards they
developed and we're all laughing because
they were all I look like her ear you
know like really close up of her feel
like you know a lot of pictures of your
face